so
raising money for this kind of thing is
pretty hard as an entrepreneur how are
because people come to me with a music
startup i'm like oh great got anything
in healthcare it's like
you're gonna fail this is a disaster
like
healthcare with the incumbents the music
industry the incumbents i'm curious how
two groups of people looked at you
because you have been successful at
raising money eventually but i'm
guessing it was harder in the beginning
before you figured this out
but that's just a guess and then i'm
curious what the music industry thinks
of you because they are persnickety and
weird and they can be at their worst
cutthroat and unethical yeah so look
this is the ultimate question right
splice was at the top of my do not do
this list
do not do like you're passionate about
this but don't do this it's going to be
a terrible idea and i had an artist
friend who got into programming after
groupme was successful and he said to me
because we started with collaboration
software and he said to me where's
github for music and it took my do not
do this list and it just took it over
the line and i was like all right i
guess i'm going to go down this crazy
ass path
and luckily coming off group me success
andy weissman from union square ventures
who was my first investor of group me
beta works and then adam dugelli from
trueventures who had to run a music
label for a while small kind of indie
label they were in but i will tell you
almost everyone else who were my initial
investors at least that the more
institutional ones were like anything
but music
like please steve any you can do
anything but don't do a music company
and look the fact that i'm on the show
on a path to try to get to 100 million
are here is is it feels like you're
building a it's the effort probably
required to get to a decacor
exactly
so what about the what about the music
industry in a way i'm thinking the music
industry likes you because you get rid
of their biggest headache which is
somebody makes an album and then their
legal department has to clean up the
mess i think that's right i think in a
moment that's my thing in this space is
not to be coming in and be like i'm mr
disrupter technology is going to change
everything i'm not going to need your
old i actually have worked really hard
to build bridges with both the you know
music industry uh the music instruments
side of the businesses i haven't been
like [ __ ] you guys where tech is coming
in and cloud and ai is going to change
everything it's really been a attempt to
build a harmonious relationship by just
doing things better and understanding
everybody's needs and desires like we
don't take away from any of the revenue
that the labels and publishers
like we're only incremental if we work
with their artists we help them write
music faster so in general i think
that's what's been cool about building a
brand like this it's a pretty loved
brand and i i take a lot of pride in
that and being able to navigate a really
really muddy territory is in this
normally cutthroat space
every startup needs business insurance
and you should look no further than a
broker if you don't have insurance you
fail one of the first steps in broker
technology saves you time and money
prices are up to 20 percent lower with
better coverage than the incumbents you
can go from sign up to quote and
purchase in just 10 minutes when you
work within broker instead of business
insurance incumbents you're not dealing
with large slow corporations plus the
sign up takes days not weeks and the
process is transparent with no opaque
pricing
here are four crucial types of startup
insurance that they cover and you're
gonna need all four of these in all
likelihood cyber insurance in case you
get hacked dno insurance so your if your
directors and officers do something dumb
and you get sued you're covered you have
eno insurance which covers errors and
omissions that's what the e and the o
stands for and it helps you scale
because many major customers will ask to
see your eno insurance in order to close
a deal and of course epl employment
practices liability discovers harassment
wrongful termination and more to
instantly buy custom-built insurance for
startups go to inbroker.com twist
that's e-m-b-r-o-k-e-r-dot-com
twist and while you're there get an
extra 10 off using the offer code you
guessed it okay let's get back to this
amazing episode